also
[Musik] in
Ordnung
hallo und willkommen alle,
es ist aktiver Livestream Nummer
47.1 am 10. August
und wir setzen unsere
Erkundungen der Papier-Dyade inaktiver dynamischer
sozialer Kognition und aktiver Inferenz
von Hippalito und Venedig
und aktiver Inferenz und Entführung durch
Pietarennen und fort  benny
Willkommen beim Act Imp Institute Wir sind ein
partizipatives Labor und Institut, das das
Lernen und Üben von
angewandter aktiver Inferenz kommuniziert
Hintergründe und Perspektiven sind
willkommen
und wir folgen der Video-Etikette
für Live-Streams.
Gehen Sie zu activeinference.org, um mehr über
andere Projekte am Institut zu erfahren und
wie Sie heute in Stream 47.1 teilnehmen und Lerngruppen beitreten können.
Wir lernen weiter und  Diskutieren Sie
diese beiden Papiere, die zuvor
und im vorherigen Video erwähnt wurden,
und
wir werden mit einigen beginnen
Einführungen und dann wahrscheinlich einfach
einspringen, wo immer
jemand eine neue Frage hat, die er
stellen möchte. Vielleicht beenden Sie
die Einführungen mit Blau, damit Sie
einen neuen Vektor in die Konversation einbringen können,
also
bin ich Daniel, ich bin ein Forscher in
Kalifornien
und  Ich freue mich darauf
, ein 0,1-
Objektiv mit einem erweiterten Punkt 0 auf das Papier zu bringen
,
da es bei einigen dieser Winkel so viel zu lernen gab
und so viel darüber
nachzudenken
, ähm
[Musik],
was ist  der unterschied
zwischen in der badewanne und dann in der
mitte des
papierpaars zu sein oder zum beispiel hineinzukommen, um es zu
kontextualisieren oder zu versuchen, es zu verlassen
, um es etwas dazwischen anzuwenden, selbst
dort gebe
ich es an äh dean weiter,
danke, ich bin  Dean, ich bin hier in Calgary,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich nicht weiß, was der
Punkt bedeutet, weil wir noch nie
einen Punkt gemacht haben, bei dem wir versucht haben, zwei Dinge zu ziehen
, sie in die Nähe zu bringen und zu sehen, was passiert
denn manchmal ist das
Feuer und Wasser und holt einfach viel
Dampf ein  Und manchmal ist es Nitro und
Glyzerin und die ganze Sache explodiert auf
dich, also freue ich mich
irgendwie darauf, das ist der
riskante Teil, den ich für aufregend halte.
Ich werde es an Stephen weitergeben.
Hallo, danke, Dean, ja  stephen hier, ich bin
in toronto, ähm,
ich bin wirklich neugierig,
was diese infusion von zwei unterschiedlichen
ansätzen zur aktiven beeinflussung hervorbringen kann, also
was steckt dahinter, alles was
hinter
einem aktivismusansatz steckt, der
instrumentalismus einbringt
, oder einem eher
mathematischen ansatz
Ich habe mich darauf konzentriert, Realismus einzubringen, also bin ich neugierig und hoffe, dass
es nützlich und praktisch sein wird.
Ich werde es an
Blue weitergeben.
Hallo, ich bin Blue, ich bin in New Mexico
Ich glaube, wir haben das Hippolyto-
Papier schon einmal in einem anderen Live-Stream gemacht, ähm,
und deshalb habe ich das schon einmal gelesen, aber ich habe es
wirklich genossen, diese
Entführung zu lesen, und ich bin in der französischen Zeitung aktiv. Ich
habe keinen starken philosophischen Hintergrund, also
komme ich irgendwie an  ist wie  mit einem was ist
das was ist das wie ich muss
100 millionen mal wikipedia durchsuchen
um mehr informationen zu bekommen
über einen philosophischen aspekt und so
eines der wichtigsten dinge wie wo ich
es schwer hatte mich
festzuhalten  Dieses Entführungspapier aktive Schlussfolgerung
und Entführung
ist ähm,
warum zuerst in Decken
wie äh, sie haben die Autoren
präsentiert, als ob die ersten und
Decken wie eine realistische
Perspektive erfordern, also ist das wahr und wenn ja,
warum ist das in
Ordnung,
danke an
alle  Zwei
blaue Fäden in dem, was ich
gehört habe, und ich denke, zwei Bereiche, in denen wir
irgendwie auf die Folie kommen und gleichzeitig sehen
können,
so dass einer wie unterschiedliche Ansätze war
, die beide von einer Person verfolgt werden können,
wie unterschiedliche Hintergründe in
verschiedenen Bereichen oder Disziplinen
und dann geht man irgendwie über den reinen Lernpfad einer Person hinaus
und denkt darüber nach, was die
konzeptionellen Ansätze sind, die
wir in diesem Fall für aktive Schlussfolgerungen verwenden können,
aber das könnte eine
Studie sein  ng aktive Schlussfolgerung und die Anwendung
aktiver Schlussfolgerungen auf beide Arten
könnten ins Spiel kommen,
und dann die Frage nach der ersten und
deckt so
etwas wie die Aspekte dessen ab, was
einen situativen Realisten
oder einen
Instrumentalisten
befähigt, warum Menschen die Haltung einnehmen, die
sie einnehmen
[Musik]
In einer bestimmten Situation,
manchmal sogar
gemischt in verschiedenen Kontexten für
dasselbe System, verwenden sie möglicherweise das eine oder
andere oder so etwas in der Art, Stephen,
und dies bringt Aktion wieder in die
Gleichung. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Aktion ziemlich
wichtig ist, weil
die Idee des Instrumentalismus in a ist  So werden
bestimmte Instrumente verwendet, ähm, und das ist
der beste Weg,
um darüber nachzudenken, was mit den Decken passiert.
Eigentlich finde ich es wirklich
cool, dass Sie die Decken zur Sprache gebracht haben,
weil, äh
, diese Frage von
äh kommt, wissen Sie, auf aktive Weise
Zum Beispiel ist die Versuchung, alles realistisch zu machen,
und dann ist es so,
dass wir eine Decke haben, also ist es irgendwie so, dass
wir vielleicht sind  Wir sollten sicherstellen, dass wir die
pauschale Frage instrumental halten
, um all diese Fallen zu vermeiden, und auf der
anderen Seite ist es wie
auf der mathematischen Seite, es ist wie
diese
potenziell grundlegenden
Dynamiken,
und da sie auf irgendeine Weise gespielt werden
, müssen sie welche haben  Beziehung zur Realität
in gewisser Weise,
also ist es fast der Spiegel,
es ist nicht der Spiegel, aber es ist etwas
, das auf interessante Weise auf der anderen Seite sitzt
Erwähnen Sie, dass
ich denke, wenn wir zwei Papiere nehmen und
tatsächlich
ein bisschen was tun, was passiert, wenn sie
verwickelt werden, schauen wir uns an, was
passiert, wenn etwas aktiv
als Prozess gefolgert wird, im Gegensatz zu
aktiver Schlussfolgerung als Gegenstand oder
Thema
und wenn wir das tun, fragen wir im Wesentlichen
,
was die großen Fragen auf einer der
nächsten Folien hier sind,
also ist aktives Schließen sowohl als Prozess
als aktives Schließen als auch als Prozess, aus dem
etwas herausfällt  Das und
wir haben es in der Verwendung der
Metapher gefragt, sowohl ein
Greifer als auch ein
Prozess zu sein, der gegriffen wird, und so ähm
ja, ich denke, wenn wir, wenn wir,
wenn wir es tatsächlich als das betrachten,
was vor sich geht, nicht nur  Aus dem
Sinn des Tuns, aber aus dem
Sinn des Beobachtens oder des Mitmachens,
ähm,
ich denke, es lässt uns keine andere Wahl, als
zu
sagen, dass es
zwischen beiden ein Hin und Her geben muss, aber
das ist nur meine Meinung
,
also lassen Sie mich dieses Zitat vorlesen
das papier ähm geht speziell
auf die decke zurück die das auslöst
meine meine meine frage klingel das ist wie
unbeantwortet
ähm es sagt
ähm okay nach neueren
interpretationen des fep kann das dynamische
zusammenspiel lebender systeme und der
außenwelt unter aktiver schlussfolgerung stehen
semantisch interpretiert werden ist dies
ein Ramstead-2020-Zitat, indem wir davon ausgehen,
dass sensorische Zustände sinnvolle
Repräsentationen der Realität sind.
Dies gilt insbesondere dann, wenn wir davon ausgehen,
dass die Entwicklung  nt von Markov-Decken
von fristen
Anders als ihre ursprüngliche Charakterisierung
und Arbeiten von Judea Pearl über
probabilistische kausale Netzwerke lassen eine
realistische Interpretation der
Beziehung zwischen dem Organismus und
der Umwelt zu,
so heißt es, während die Rolle der
Konzepte von Markov-Decken und
Perlendecken in vielen Behandlungen  des Freie-
Energie-Prinzips ist ein
instrumentalistisches, während in Pierces noch stärkeren
Begriffen eine nominalistische
Interpretation ihrer Bedeutung zugestehen, zuerst in
Decken sind nicht nur im
nicht-instrumentalistischen Sinne realistisch, sondern auch in
dem Sinne, dass
die modalen Begriffe nicht-nominalistische Einheiten sind  von Hinweisen
auf reale Möglichkeiten, wie das
Denkbare oder Imaginierte
oder antizipatorisch auf
zukünftige Sachverhalte bezogene, werden
verwendet, um die Schlüsselaspekte der
Theorie zu
verstehen, ähm und so in meiner Erinnerung das erste in der Decke, wie ich es getan habe.  Das ist nicht unbedingt per se
mit Realismus verbunden,
also
Daniel wie vielleicht Ken do yo  Sie haben eine
weitere Klarstellung, wie z. B., dass wie ein
Realist eine Decke zum ersten Mal eine
realistische Interpretation der
Perlendecke ist, oder vergesse ich nur,
dass ich beim Lesen dieses Teils
nicht wusste, was Nominalismus ist,
so die Zusammenfassung
der Ansicht  dass Universalien und abstrakte
Objekte nicht wirklich existieren, außer
dass sie nur
Namen oder Bezeichnungen sind.
Eine Version leugnet die Existenz von
Universalien,
die andere die abstrakte, also ist es eine
anti-generalistische Position, also lassen Sie uns sehen,
wo das mit der ersten und
pauschalen verwendet wurde,
weil dies die ist  ähm
[Musik]
Kernpunkt der Diskussion wie eine der
Berührungsgrenzen,
abgesehen davon, dass Aktivismus
und dynamische Systemtheorie
so grob funktionieren oder dieses breite Gebiet, in dem Mathematik
und Chemie so zusammenarbeiten,
beginnt, in den wirklichen
Kontakt zu treten
Semantische Revierpunkte, um die
gekämpft wird, haben unterschiedliche
Perspektiven,
wie
Basisgraphen in unterschiedlichen Kontexten zu interpretieren sind,
und so dann t  Die Markov-Decke
scheint immer noch zu
grobkörnig
zu sein, als dass dieser ganze Rasen
von der einen oder anderen Ansicht kontrolliert werden könnte.
Schauen wir uns also an,
wie das Entführungspapier
und alles andere, was Sie
sehen,
in Ihrem Sinne gerechtfertigter wäre
ähm
[Musik]
was und dann packen wir das aus, weil
ich denke, das wurde nur hineinkopiert,
um heute zu diskutieren,
da es offensichtlich ein klarer Bereich ist, in dem
beide Zeitungen über ihre Sicht
auf die Markup-Decke sprechen, was
es klarer
machen könnte, wie vielzählig  Ansichten auf
Decken und Diagramme
kommen ins Spiel,
aber packen wir ihre beiden
Perspektiven aus,
sehen die nominalistische UM-
Interpretation und da Sie das
auspacken, als müsste ich
nicht nachschlagen, weil es ein
sehr ähm prominentes Thema im Buddhismus ist
dass ähm, wissen Sie,
es ist wie das Fehlen jeglicher Art von
inhärenter Existenz, wie diese
Existenz nominell ist,
und deshalb ist es interessant, dass sie in diesem
ähm Entführungspapier
dies nehmen  ähm,
du kennst Konstruktion durch Durchbohren des
Nominalismus, aber auch wie mehr als
einmal in diesem Artikel
weisen sie auf eine objektive Realität hin, ähm, die so
ist, wenn Dinge interp
interpretiert werden, wenn alle Sachen nominell
interpretiert werden,
dann
ähm,
was ist diese objektive Realität anders
als wie  Linguistik oder Semantik oder
vielleicht Semiotik
ähm ja, das ist
sogar
ein sehr guter Punkt ähm, weil es
auch auf das zurückgeht, was Sie erwähnt haben ähm,
als wir darüber sprachen, dass die
Beziehung fast die Realität ist, spürte ich,
dass sie sagen wollten, ob
es eine Beziehung gibt
Diese relationalen Dynamiken oder sie haben das Wort Dynamik nicht verwendet,
daher
können
einige
als real bezeichnet werden,
was meiner Meinung nach in gewisser Hinsicht eine faire Behauptung ist,
obwohl
Sie wiederum wissen, dass es
eine Überdehnung geben könnte, weil
es eine Frage gibt, wie viel Sie gehen
hoch ins Transzendente
und wie sehr man runtergeht
in
die Art von mehr Morphologie und
die ganze Morphogenese und da ist
wirklich eine wirkliche Gänsehaut  d
es gibt einen Hector Lazar, er macht eigentlich
viel Arbeit mit dem Theater der Unterdrückten
und hat mit Ihnen gearbeitet,
Sie wissen, dass Menschen gefoltert wurden und
solche Sachen, und er spricht darüber,
ähm, die Medizin ist in den Wunden, die
Medizin ist in den Wunden, wenn Menschen
Lernen Sie
Traumata usw. kennen, und eines der
interessanten Dinge ist, dass
wir in einer Kultur sein können, in
der wir manchmal versuchen, Dinge zu erklären oder
transzendentale Arbeit zu leisten
, um eine Situation zu überwinden
oder uns zu vermeiden, und wir können eine Situation tatsächlich vermeiden
aber manchmal, wenn Sie in die Wunde gehen, ist
das,
was Sie finden könnten, buchstäblich ein
blutiges Durcheinander,
so
dass es im normalen Sinne vielleicht nicht echt ist.
Wissen
Sie, fügen wir dem einfach ein bisschen hinzu. Ich
denke, es ist interessant, dass die meisten
Darstellungen von Markov-Decken zeigen
Die Markov-
Decke zwischen
zwei
unterschiedlichen
Sätzen von Eigenschaften, und das wird
immer auf der Horizontalen dargestellt,
und ich denke, was hier interessant ist
, ist, wenn Sie
genau wenn Sie finden  Sie befinden sich
in einer
Debattensituation mit zwei Top-Down-Perspektiven, eine, die
besagt, dass
es von oben nach unten und aktiv
sein muss, oder es muss von oben nach unten eine
Reihe von
Reihen oder eine Reihe unterschiedlicher
Logiken angewendet werden, je nachdem, wie Sie damit vertraut
sind  Was Sie beobachten
, kann zu dieser ganzen Frage der
Hierarchie führen, und dann, was das
andere mit sich bringt, also für mich,
ähm, es ist ziemlich
einfach zu verstehen, warum
Leute, die
die ausschließliche Position des
Instrumentalismus einnehmen, so
etwas wie Logik
oder beinhalten  die andere hierarchische
beziehung
der logik ist die reale sache
und dann
die zu befolgenden handlungen, oder das ist die
sache, die dazugehört.
ich denke, was die diagramme vieler
bilder uns sagen, ist, dass es auch einen
seitlichen aspekt gibt,
und so, wenn wir  Wir werden
uns diese seitliche Betrachtung ansehen,
die die andere
Top-Down-Ansicht umhüllt, weil
beide Ansichten in diesen beiden
Papieren
die Voreingenommenheit oder
die Position th sind  Die Autoren nehmen
eine von oben nach unten,
was
unter diesen Bedingungen oder
Umständen regiert,
indem sie diese beiden Dinge nebeneinander stellen,
einige der Fragen zur
Relativitätstheorie beseitigen
und nun die Idee einer Rundum-Beziehung einführen,
nicht einer Beziehung in Bezug
auf Macht über
Aber die Beziehung in Bezug darauf,
was vorhanden sein muss, damit
jemand tatsächlich
weniger Vorhersagefehler machen kann,
so dass
die Markup-Decke, von der ich denke,
dass sie gedreht werden kann,
ich meine, im Moment das meiste davon
als eine Art
vertikale Partition wahrgenommen wird  zwischen
seitlichen
Elementen, ich meine, es kann umgedreht werden, und
wir haben oft in vielen Artikeln
darüber gesprochen, was die hierarchische Struktur ist,
was von unten nach oben ist, was von oben nach unten ist,
aber ich denke, beide dieser Artikel
sagen zugegebenermaßen, dass
wir eine Top-down-Ansicht einnehmen  dies,
und deshalb beschränken sie
sich darauf,
den Relativitätsaspekt dessen, was darin vor sich geht, stärker zu betonen, und zwar
auf eine aktiv
schlussfolgernde Weise, als sie sehen  Betrachten Sie
es als eine Beziehung zwischen dem Wahrnehmen
und dem Handeln.
Okay,
wow, eine Menge Zeug. Lassen
Sie uns die Entführungsdiskussion
durchgehen  die Linien der
Autopoiesis und der Biologie, also sind dies
Systeme, die
sich vielleicht in einem diffusen, multiskaligen Selbstweg selbst
aufrechterhalten,
aber sie sind selbsterschaffend, wir nehmen sie nicht einfach so
, als
ob sie vor fünf Minuten in einer bestimmten erfundenen Anordnung
existierten.  Denken Sie an Systeme
,
die einen stabilen
Nichtgleichgewichtszustand mit ihrer Umgebung aufrechterhalten haben,
und wenn nicht an die Umgebung, wenn jemand
den Realismus oder das
irgendetwas der Umgebung leugnet,
dann
kann das verbalisiert und sogar erkannt werden, aber
es wird auch nicht von persistenten Systemen in Kraft gesetzt
aus der ansicht von innen
oder wie wenn man einfach
aufhört zu atmen oder so
oder die ansicht von außen weil
wieder systeme mit p  Anhaltende
Messungen
müssen zumindest
gut genug sein, um
inmitten der Regelmäßigkeiten der
Umwelt zu bestehen,
also ist dies so, als würde man sie in
einem evolutionären und entwicklungsbezogenen
Rahmen verankern, aber sie mit der
Aufrechterhaltung des stationären Nichtgleichgewichts verbinden,
die diese Realismusdiskussion
begründet  eine Beziehung mit der
Umgebung
nicht so wie in a priori,
dann gibt es eine Definition von Markov, die
den pauschalen Zustand bedingte
Unabhängigkeit zwischen Knoten in einem Basisdiagramm abdeckt,
was nicht bedeutet, dass sich der Einfluss
nicht ausbreitet oder dass diese
Zustände semantisch nicht von jedem sind  andere,
aber es bedeutet, dass sie
auf statistische Weise bedingt unabhängig sind
externe Zustände
in sabosku Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob dieser Autor, aber die
endosomische Sichtweise
möglicherweise bedeutet, dass auf der Innenseite
Photonen auf der Netzhaut wirklich Licht sind.
Es ist wirklich der Fall, dass dies der Fall ist
reale Sache
innerhalb dieser Facette der biologischen Funktion
und der inneren Zustände, die von der
Exosemiotik beschrieben werden  Perspektive, vielleicht wie
die interpretative Sicht, also von
innen sehen, den wahren Einfluss eines
Merkmals
und die Art, es zu studieren,
von außen betrachten, wo diejenigen übereinstimmen, dass
Sie eine Semiose haben, wie bei einem Stoppschild,
und es bedeutet,
in der Situation mit etwas anderem aufzuhören
Dies spricht direkt für aktive
Inferenz, da die Regulierung der
Entropie interner Zustände, also all diese
Funktionen, die wir
als begrenzt oder eingeschränkt oder minimiert beschreiben
, mit
der überraschenden Kontrolle dieser Schnittstelle über
ausgehende Aktionen und dann begrenzte
Überraschung zu tun haben  auf die Wahrnehmung, die
auch sehr stark gealtert ist, wie die
Theorie der Wahrnehmungskontrolle und verschiedene
Motortheorien, über die wir gesprochen haben,
aber wie der Reflexbogen
, der die Art und Weise in Frage stellt, wie Menschen die
Entscheidungsfindung modelliert haben,
dann
ähm, in vielen Behandlungen sind sie sich
einig, dass Menschen  einen
instrumentalistischen gebrauch oder eine instrumentalistische
haltung einnehmen sind nicht nur
in der nicht-instrumentalisten-se realistisch  nse
eröffnet eine ganze Diskussion mit non und
anti,
aber auch im Sinne von
nicht nominalistischen Einheiten,
und dann in diesem letzten Zitat
ähm,
es wäre großartig, mehr von den Autoren darüber zu hören,
was die modalen
Referenzbedingungen sind, aber der Teil  Was
hier heraussticht, sind die realen Möglichkeiten,
denn für diese Systeme
mit diesen Merkmalen, die auf diese Weise eingreifen, kann
ihre Wahrnehmung
insofern als real angesehen werden, als sie alle diese
Merkmale aufweist und im Laufe der Zeit an die Umgebung gebunden ist,
und so weiter.
Hoffentlich
ist das eine Sichtweise  darauf, weil viele
Absätze im abduktiven Papier und im
inaktiven Papier,
wenn Sie sich wirklich mit ihren
strukturierten Argumenten beschäftigen, so
viel zwischendurch lesen
und
die Art und Weise, wie sie das Argument angelegt haben, zu respektieren,
während
hoffentlich jetzt alle
interessante Wege dazu sehen  Verbinde es also,
Stephen und dann alle anderen,
ja, das ist eine
Art Rückkopplung zu dir, Daniel, also für den
Fall, dass du darüber nachdenkst, aber
weil
du das weißt.  Es gibt
hier den biologischen Aspekt, den Sie ansprechen
, und dem stimme ich zu,
und
Sie wissen, dass Tristan in seiner Arbeit über das Gehirn
davon gesprochen hat
, von einer, sagen wir, kausalen Korrelation zu
einer funktionellen Korrelation zu gelangen,
und es kann viele Wege geben, dorthin zu gelangen
Irgendwo, wenn es funktional ist,
also, aber in diesem Fall
gibt es natürlich ein gewisses Element dessen,
was in Bezug auf das, was wir wissenschaftlich wissen, real ist,
denn es ist wissenschaftlicher
Realismus als Wissenschaftler,
was wirklich wissenschaftlich abgeleitet wurde.
Wenn es also deduktiv war, ist es eine
Perspektive, die ist  Unter
der Perspektive, die auf
bestimmte
Zustände eingenommen wird, nicht gleichgewichtige stationäre Zustände,
wo ist
dieses
Regime der Aufmerksamkeit, das wissenschaftliche
Regime der Aufmerksamkeit, ein
reines Instrument, das betrachtet werden muss, oder
ist es
für die Dinge, die es analysiert,
die real sein könnten,
so dass es sie geben könnte  eine Art
Ausstiegsklausel,
aber es könnte immer noch ein
Phänomen
statt
Perspektiven und Logik
dahinter sitzen  t, die
viele Dynamiken haben, um zum gleichen Ergebnis zu kommen.
Also, was denkst du darüber,
Daniel,
meine Gedanken, ich möchte hören, was Blue und
Dean dazu
sagen würden  Ich möchte hören, was
Sie zu sagen haben. Okay,
also hier ist eine interessante Sache
zu beiden Artikeln, und vielleicht werden die
Autoren der Artikel dies hart zurückdrängen,
aber großartig, das ist es, was ich daran gewöhnt
bin, dass
beide Artikel eine wissenschaftliche Perspektive einnehmen
sehr viel ist meine typische Perspektive,
die in meinen Büchern leicht
als Redewendung zu verstehen ist,
wenn ich es sehe, werde ich es glauben, sie wollen
die Beweise richtig, sie wollen es, sie
wollen, dass diese Art von induktivem, deduktivem
Stück sozusagen vorne und in der Mitte sitzt, die
sie wollen  Beweis,
was großartig ist, ich verstehe das, aber was
ich wirklich faszinierend daran finde, ist,
während sie
diese epistemische Priorität hochhalten, über die
sie auch viel reden,
werden sie das umkehren und sagen, ich werde es
glauben,
wenn ich es kann  siehe es
Es gibt also viel Vertrauen darin, es
hat sich noch nicht verwirklicht, aber wenn ich
weiterhin
in einem sozialen Umfeld
oder als Agent existiere,
raten Sie mal, was ich Vertrauen haben muss, dass ich die
ganze Zeit, die sich
ausbreitet,
für was auch immer weitermachen werde  Ziele oder
Anweisungen, die ich nehme
,
um durch
das Nichtsehen zu arbeiten,
bis ich tatsächlich
in dem Moment ankomme, in dem etwas
zustande kommt und ich sagen kann, oh,
jetzt habe ich die Beweise, also gibt es
beide Papiere haben ein echtes,
sie spielen, sie spielen mit sich selbst, sie
tanzen mit sich selbst in dem Sinne, dass
beide Papiere von einem expliziten
Standpunkt aus sind, der besagt, dass wir
das wissenschaftlich und mathematisch betrachten
und dennoch in der Lage sind
, an
diesem Gedanken oder dieser Idee festzuhalten, dass der fpp
Sie ist  Ich weiß, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin,
ich bin, was auch immer Steady State genannt wird. Ich habe
gerade den Ausdruck Nicht-Gleichgewicht verloren.
Danke, Nicht-Gleichgewichts-Zustand
Ö  Das
Ergebnis, auf das ich mich zubewege, ob das
Homöostase oder Allostase ist oder ob ich in
fünf Minuten ein Sandwich machen möchte, ich muss
an diese Sache glauben oder an meine Entscheidungsfreiheit oder meine
Fähigkeit, etwas zu erreichen oder zu erreichen,
bevor ich
das Ding tatsächlich
haben kann  Allein aus dieser Sicht
finde ich es wirklich interessant, dass
es
in beiden Zeitungen eine gewisse Naivität gibt. Wir
müssen unseren Hut vor dieser Anfängeransicht ziehen,
dass jedes Mal, wenn wir
etwas erkennen
, ein bisschen Vertrauen erforderlich ist  oder
ein wenig glauben
an das, was vor sich geht, diese prioritäten
existieren tatsächlich und ich werde sie verwenden,
weil ich ausführen möchte, was auch immer meine
prioritäten sind,
und es spielt keine
rolle, ob es die top downiness von
entführung und logik oder das top ist
Niedergeschlagenheit eines Aktivismus,
sie ziehen beide ihren Hut auf den Grund,
ich muss irgendwie ein
Vertrauen haben,
dass, selbst wenn es jetzt nicht da
ist,
es irgendwann entweder so weitergehen wird, wie ich
es will oder was auch immer  Ange, ich möchte ihm
auferlegen, dass ich die Fähigkeit habe, es
abzuwarten und das Ding passieren zu lassen,
also
ja, das würde ich zu dem hinzufügen, was
Stephen gesagt hat
Nun, der Unterschied
zwischen einem
First und dem, was der First in
Blanket ist, und ich bin auf ein Papier gestoßen, das
wir diskutieren müssen, äh, es
heißt wissenschaftlicher Realismus über First in
Blankets ohne Wortwörtlichkeit und es ist von
Kimberstein und Kirk Kirchoff,
also eines Tages  Wir müssen jetzt haben,
dass es ein Vorabdruck im
philosophischen Archiv ist, also kann es
anscheinend so sein, als ob eine echte
Grenze wörtlich sein könnte, als ob
es eine wörtliche Interpretation oder
eine realistische Interpretation gäbe, und so, als
ob ich es immer noch versuche  Um
einzugrenzen, was ist diese realistische
Interpretation einer ersten Decke, ähm
und
ja,
es ist auch in einem sehr realen Sinne, wie,
was die wahre Grenze eines Lebewesens ist,
ähm, als ob
ich meine wahre Grenze nicht finden könnte,
wie wo  höre ich auf und etwas anderes
beginnt ähm da sind Hunderte
und Billionen Ich weiß nicht einmal mehr
nicht-menschliche Zellen in meinem Körper
als menschliche Zellen, also muss ich immer darauf
zurückkommen also was wäre ich
ohne  All diese nicht-menschlichen Dinge
sind diese nicht-menschlichen Dinge, die ich auch mag,
aber wie du weißt, nehme ich
ständig neue auf und scheide alte
aus und so weiter, und sie kommen
in meine Haut und verlassen meine Haut so
Wo ist meine
Grenze wie muss ich diese
Grenze haben, damit aktive Schlussfolgerungen möglich sind
und wie die Markov-Decke-Interpretation angewendet wird?
Ich weiß nicht
, dass das
unbedingt wahr ist,
also
kann ich einfach davon loskommen. Ich liebe
dieses Papier und ich  Liebe wie die semiotische
Interpretation wie der abduktive
Sinn wie aber spielt es überhaupt eine
Rolle wie
so die wirklichste Interpretation wie für
jemanden, der nicht daran glaubt wie eine
gemeinsame objektive Realität wird
niemals funktionieren
oder wie kannst du die Grenze finden  wie
was ist diese linie zwischen selbst und anderen
oder wie zwischen
wie wie ich kann die grenze nicht finden so
wie für mich ist das alles eine modellierende
perspektive ähm, die die auswirkung
dieser entführung als aktives schlussfolgerungspapier
für mich überhaupt nicht mindert like  Als ob ich wirklich dachte, dass
es ein großartiges Papier war und viele
wirklich coole Dinge über Kognition und Wahrnehmung zu sagen hat,
also warum hängen wir immer noch daran fest, ich
weiß nicht,
okay, ihr beide macht es und dann werde ich es tun
füge ein paar Notizen hinzu,
könnte ich noch eine hinzufügen,
ich meine, ich denke, was
ich mit Dean völlig übereinstimme, bei
diesem Bottom-up-
Phänomen, du weißt
, dass es im Hintergrund da sein wird,
vielleicht wird es immer unerkennbar sein,
abgesehen von einigen davon  Diese Simulationen
geben uns Einblicke, aber
ich denke auch, was Blau sagt,
für mich ist
diese ganze Grenzfrage,
wo das Problem mit der
Systemdiskussion
in Bezug darauf liegt, dass sie irgendwie
eingebürgert ist,
und ich denke, das liegt daran, dass Sie am Ende
Witz haben  h, weil Systeme so definiert sind
, was drinnen ist, was draußen ist,
und für mich die große Offenbarung,
und ich denke, für viele Leute in
den Biowissenschaften ist
es vielleicht nicht so ungewöhnlich, so zu denken,
aber über agentenbasierte
Modellierung nachzudenken, um darüber nachzudenken, wo ist  der agent wo ist
die agentur die teleologie
und
diese
agentur sitzt nicht unbedingt an einer
grenze
, so wie systeme dazu neigen,
ich meine, jemand kann argumentieren, dass es nicht
muss und ich bin mir sicher, dass es nicht muss, aber es
endet  Es endet fast immer
genau dort in der Realität in Bezug auf den Diskurs,
also wissen Sie, wir wollen, dass dieser
Diskurs klar ist. Wir machen diese Arbeit mit
Systems Engineering, um ihn dort zu haben, wo
wir diese klaren Unterteilungen für den
Zweck des ontologischen Diskurses haben wollen, also wir
wissen, wovon wir reden und warum
aber
wo ist vielleicht eine herausforderung
dieser agent
agentur teleologie morphologisch
ähm
dynamik ist etwas anderes und ich werde
das an daniel weitergeben und vielleicht werden seine ameisen
c  Komm irgendwo rein, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
Dean, dann mach ich es. Ich bin ganz
schnell hier, also in einigen der
Diagramme weiß ich,
Daniel, du bist wirklich gut darin,
einige der Diagramme, die Markov-Decke
ist buchstäblich ein Oval mit dem Wort
Diskrepanz
darin,
und alles, was ich tun würde, um
dem hinzuzufügen, was Blau gesagt hat, ist,
dass,
wenn Sie eine harte physische Grenze wollen und
Sie herausfinden möchten, was das ist,
ähm, ich glaube, Sie suchen  Nochmals,
was
wo ist das wo ist, endet eine
Sache und beginnt eine andere Sache als
Relativitätsfrage. Ich schlage
vor,
wenn Sie von unten nach oben und von
oben nach unten als eine Beziehung betrachten, nicht als ein
Was ist, was ist  mächtiger oder hat
mehr Einfluss auf den anderen, du
betrachtest das als eine Beziehung, dann ist
es diese Beziehung,
die
als Diskrepanzzone gilt,
es ist nicht unbedingt etwas, das
einen physischen
Anfang und ein Ende hat,
es ist irgendwie fließend
und es
und das ist  um nicht zu sagen, dass wir
die Relativit nicht betrachten sollten  Alles in allem heißt es zu
sagen, lasst uns ein Auge auf das
Relativitätsstück und das andere Auge auf das
Beziehungsstück werfen
Es bedeutet, dass
wir uns
über nichts anderes sicher sind, als dass sie
unterschiedlich sind.
Wir wissen nicht,
wo die Trennungsgrenze ist, aber
das ist sozusagen der Ursprung
dieser ganzen Sache,
denn
wenn wir aktiv sind  Wenn wir schlussfolgern,
dass wir diese Diskrepanz umgehen können,
muss es nicht immer eine Partition sein
, die das ist
, was die Erschwinglichkeit hier
möglicherweise ist, wenn wir
zwei
Dinge gleichzeitig oder
gleichzeitig haben
können  mit den
Diskrepanzen im Lehrbuch Abbildung zwei drei
Diskrepanz
keine Decke oder Diskrepanz als Decke
von Decke usw.
und
das kann ein kontinuierlicher oder diskreter
Wert sein, aber in nicht idealisiertem
wie nicht singulärem Pfad von lea  st action
settings
alias real settings gibt es immer einen
Wert ungleich Null
, also ist das eine Möglichkeit, die Tür
immer ein wenig offen
zu lassen,
so dass es nicht wirklich funktioniert, wenn man nur zwei Füße auf
Null oder Eins
oder schnelle Wechselstrategien von
Nullen und Einsen hat  Erfassen Sie
diese
ebenso blaue großartige Frage, wie
wir am Anfang ein wenig darüber
nachgedacht haben, warum jemand dazu gebracht wird, so etwas
wie eine Decke in einem realistischen oder
instrumentalistischen Licht zu betrachten,
und auf Faktoren wie die
Persistenz des Organismus hingewiesen und  Die
Realität, wie die Aktion im Fluss mit
ihrer Umgebung ist, zwingt
jemanden sozusagen zu sagen, wenn die
Umgebung real ist, dann sind die Entität und die Aktionen
und die Semiose ihrer Aktionen
real, wenn Stoppschilder real sind und das Anhalten
an einem Stoppschild real ist  real und sie sind alle
Teil eines stationären Nichtgleichgewichtszustands,
was für einen weiteren
Realismus will man wissen, als
dass es ein Territorium gibt,
und dann sind dies die Karten des
Territoriums so  Jemand wird den ganzen
Weg in die Gebietsskepsis gehen
oder wie wird er dann seine Haltung umgestalten, ähm
dann
zu den nur ein paar anderen zufälligen Teilen,
dies war in Live-Stream drei,
als wir über Kommunikation
in aktiver Inferenz lasen,
und das sind viele  In der
sozialen Inaktivitätsumgebung bringen wir
dieses abduktive
Licht in die soziale und aktive Umgebung
, die wirklich so ist, wie
in Hippolytas und Vans Artikel
erläutert, dass dies in viele der
wissenschaftlichen und philosophischen Aspekte des
Sozialen
einfließt, also hier
sie'  Wiederaufnahme
des Rahmens von Tim
Bergens vier Fragen
und Bereitstellung
mehrerer
Analyseskalen
, die alle wie die vier y sind,
und diese vier y sind so etwas wie ein
Zwei-mal-Zwei-Quadrant,
und das ermöglicht in der
Biologie
parallele Forschungsagenden
und Integration,
weil sie ähnlich sind  Die Tatsache, dass Gehirnregionen
hier oben auf der Mechanismusseite miteinander verbunden sind,
ist Teil des Bildes, aber es ist ein Ja
und mit dem Muster von
DNA-Divergenzen können
sich Situationen vorstellen, in denen sie
korreliert sind oder nicht, und sie könnten verursacht sein
oder nicht, und es könnte entweder eine
Art der Kausalität oder ein verwirrender Faktor
oder eine beliebige andere Anzahl von Dingen sein,
und dann hat keines von beiden eine direkte
geschlossene Tür  weiter so, wie der Vogelgesang
klingt, ohne auch nur darauf einzugehen,
wie der Vogelgesang interpretiert wird,
da
innerhalb dieses
interpretativen oder semiotischen wissenschaftlichen
Ansatzes
noch Raum
ist, den
wir hoffentlich erkunden können, wenn wir
die Forschung und die Anwendung
auf andere Weise als betrachten  Es wurde
in der Vergangenheit in bestimmte spezifische Analysen unterteilt,
Dekan
gut,
also werde ich hier etwas da draußen werfen,
wissend, dass ich nicht wirklich mehr darüber
nachgedacht habe, als während ich
Ihnen zuhörte,
also wenn es völlig falsch
ist, kann es jemand tun  Korrigieren Sie mich ganz
schnell. Ich finde es wirklich interessant,
dass
diese beiden Papiere das
liefern, was ich als
stabiles oder stabilisierendes EF bezeichnen würde  effekt auf das,
was
wir als etwas beschreiben könnten
, das strategie ähnelt,
für das potenzial für strategie,
woran ich immer denke, ist, dass die strategie kein verhaltensverhalten ist, das
normalerweise mit dem etikett taktik bezeichnet wird
, sondern strategie beinhaltet die
antizipation und die angewandte logik,
und ich denke  Das ist der Punkt, an dem
wir nicht im Konflikt stehen, wenn wir sagen, dass
es eine Triade und eine
Ko-Konstruktion der sozialen Szene gibt,
weil ich denke, dass beide
Dinge die Stabilität oder die Plattform bieten
, um diese Vorhersagefehler strategisch zu planen und zu minimieren,
damit
wir es wieder können  Trotzdem können wir immer noch
auf der Strategie aufbauen und tun,
und wir können immer noch auf der Strategie aufbauen
und
ständig schlechte Folgeentscheidungen eliminieren. Das ist
also
wieder die Beziehung, im
Gegensatz zu
welchem dieser beiden Ansätze diese beide
Top-Down-Ansät
ze das Ding sind  hat den größten
Einfluss, weil zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt das
eine oder das andere oder beides
tatsächlich der Fall wäre, solange Sie nicht in einem gefangen sind  Die meisten, die ich denke,
wären die meisten Optionen, die nicht
ausgewählt wurden, weil sie im
Einführungspapier über
die verschiedenen Arten
der Entführung sprechen,
aber sie betonen auch stark,
dass am Ende beide dieser Arten das
Erzeugen und das Auswählen
im Wesentlichen
Sie sind  Sie können das eine nicht ohne
das andere haben
,
also ist das auch eine interessante Sache
, die Sie hier integrieren können,
oder Sie müssen bedenken, dass ich nicht sage, dass
Sie es aufgreifen müssen,
aber wenn Sie es tun würden, wie würde das aussehen
? Ich werde es tun  Reagieren Sie direkt ein paar Stücke
dort dann Steven als jeder andere so
sehr interessante Verbindung mit
Multiskalen-Vorhersagefehler oder Freie-Energie-Minimierung Unsicherheitsreduzierung Surprisal Bounding in Multiskalensystemen
und dann in diesem sozial inaktiven Umfeld
, das
Hippolyta und Vanness in den
Vordergrund gerückt haben
Das ist
unser Greifer und so gegriffen
, dass ein kleines
Experiment
mit einem aktiven Inferenzsystem mit festem Spiegel
oder einem System, das von einem der
Konvente beschrieben wird  ionale mechanik klassische physik mechanik statistische thermodynamik quantenmechanischer einstieg in eine art vorspiel
zu
bevorstehenden diskussionen mit dalton,
aber ich denke, wir werden einen
aspekt hervorheben, nämlich dass die bayes'sche
mechanik
diese diskussion auf die
kognitive
dynamik aktiver teilchen
und so weiter ausdehnt  Auf diese Weise wird ein fallender Ball
zu einem Sonderfall des
Fallens aktiver Partikel
, die je nach ihren verkörperten Angeboten verschiedene Wege einschlagen könnten,
selbst wenn sie nur so beschrieben werden, als ob der
Baseball nicht der Parabelgleichung
folgt, aber so interagieren die reale
Umgebung und das aktive Partikel
das heißt semiotisch,
weshalb beide
Artikel Entführungen im sozialen Kontext
erwähnen, und dann erwähnten Sie diese beiden
Top-Down-Perspektiven
und wie, wenn wir die Divergenz
zwischen einem Problem mit mehreren drei Körpern haben
, wir hoffentlich mehrere Ideen haben,
mindestens zwei
mehr
und dann gibt es seltsame anziehungskräfte es
gibt da
gibt es live str  eam 32 es gibt
Livestream 26 alles passiert in diesem
Raum von oben nach unten,
weil es immer eine
Vielzahl von unten nach oben geben wird,
also ist der einzige Fehler, der
mit Sicherheit nicht
nur die richtige grobe Körnung wäre
,
ein einzelnes
Auge von Mordor
Laser
und  Das führt im
Grunde zu den unerwarteten Unerwarteten
mit der Realität von unten nach oben,
und wenn es dann Divergenzen und
kontinuierliche Zustandsräume und Pfade
zwischen oben nach unten
gibt, dann gibt es eine bidirektionale
Beziehung zwischen oben nach unten und
unten nach oben oder von innen nach außen und dem
außen nach innen, weil man sich sogar
zwischen diesen bewegen konnte, ohne das Gefühl zu haben, dass
wir wie ein Systemverstoß waren
, manchmal von links nach rechts für
Zeit zu gehen, und dann konnten wir von rechts nach links
für Zeit gehen und so diese Art von
kognitiven Bewegungen als zugänglich
in einem sozialen Umfeld ansehen  Einstellung
und dann Schnittbindung, die natürlich zuletzt zu
Ihnen gesagt haben, dass der Zweitaktmotor der
Entführung mit Generieren und Auswählen,
weil der Laser kein Generator ist
Und das ist jetzt die Analogie der
Aufmerksamkeit
in einem System des Herunterredens, wie wir
modelliert und mentale Aktion
mehrere Male gesehen haben, Stephen,
ja, danke, Daniel,
ähm, könntest du zu den
Vier mal Vieren zurückkehren, die du dort hattest, ähm,
mit dem ultimativen Ja  und
ich denke, dass dies wirklich wichtig ist,
weil
es auch diese implizite Erleuchtungsannahme
gibt, die immer im Hintergrund saß,
wo oben gut ist,
und
ich denke, es ist wirklich interessant,
dass und ich denke, Sie haben absolut Recht,
wir sprechen darüber, was über das Ultimative spricht
Ich denke, es ist wirklich neugierig und es
spricht über Sie wissen, dass wir über diese Interaktionen sprechen,
also diese Art von Interaktion,
das ist die ultimative Reihe von Interaktionen,
das Rotkehlchen, und
das ist, was die Wahrheit als
die rationale Wahrheit angesehen wird,
wenn wir nach oben gehen und wir bekommen  Erleuchtet,
also können wir auf das herunter projizieren,
was da ist, und die Idee, dass
das, was aufkommt,
Interaktionen sind, das ist die allgemeine Art und Weise, wie es
gedacht wird, und da war diese Zauberkiste
ca  Ich habe die Emergenz dazu gebracht,
die Tatsache zu umgehen, dass wir es wirklich nicht wussten,
aber ich würde, ich würde das in Frage stellen,
nicht um nicht zu sagen, dass das in
Bezug auf die Wahrnehmung nicht stimmt, aber es
gibt einen anderen Weg, wie es von unten nach oben
erforscht werden kann, und das ist  Eine andere Möglichkeit, die
Wahrheit zu erforschen, ist die
rationale Wahrheit
und die, von
der ich dachte, dass sie das Letzte ist, ich habe
das Gefühl, dass das
sehr nach außen schaut, da
diese Annahme, die Erleuchtung
, in diese Worte eingebaut ist, aber es gibt auch eine intime Wahrheit
Die intime
Wahrheit unterscheidet sich von der rationalen Wahrheit
und bei der intimen Wahrheit geht es nicht um
Interaktionen, es geht um das Wissen,
okay,
es geht um eine tiefere Art des Wissens.
Wenn ich also nach unten gehe, ist es nicht das,
was von unten nach oben kommt,
sondern das, was mir
gut geht, meine einzige Möglichkeit, mich zu engagieren  Es
macht Sinn
, sich darauf einzulassen, und dass
es auch wertvoll
ist, sich darauf einzulassen, es ist nicht primitiver
als Erleuchtung,
und ich denke
, das geht in etwa so  Eine sehr
grundlegende Annahme, die wir nicht
einmal bemerken, es geht um die Wissenschaft,
dass alles versucht, aufgeklärt zu werden,
aber das
ist nur teilweise wahr, und ich denke, die
Biologie weiß das irgendwie, kann aber vielleicht
sowieso nicht damit sprechen, das ist
mein kleines Stück da
Um zu versuchen, diese eine Ebene näher mit einigen akademischen Traditionen zu verbinden, denke ich, aber auf keinen Fall genormten, aber danke für alle, die diese geteilt haben
Hier ist Evelyn Fox Kellers Biografie
von Barbara McClintock
und der Titel ist ein Gefühl für den
Organismus
und ähm
, das
nimmt eine
Geschichte und Wissenschaftsphilosophie
informierte Sichtweise ein, wie zum Beispiel, was ist das Gefühl
für den Organismus,
wie hat man ein Gefühl für die
Chromosomen?  dieser Glaube, dass es
aus
bestimmten psychologischen Beobachtungen springende Gene gab,
und
wie spielt sich das dann wirklich ab, wenn sich
jemand in einem Kontext
von Professionalität befindet  und wie Erwartungen an
verschiedene Menschen, die
unterschiedlich aussehen und so weiter
, also nimmt man einen ganzheitlichen Blick und ich
denke, es gibt in jedem oder
vielen Fällen
diese Art von Geschichte zu erzählen,
und
das ist eine blaue Verbindungsbrücke,
wie vom Evolutionsstandpunkt aus gesehen  und ich
denke, ähm,
wie ein
Teil der Frage, die Stephen
zuvor gestellt hat, wie können wir mehrere
Trajektorien nehmen, sei es von oben nach unten, von unten nach
oben, um zu derselben Schlussfolgerung zu gelangen
, oder zum gleichen Endpunkt,
ähm,
und das ist so etwas wie in der Evolution,
es gibt wie eine konvergente Evolution  wo
Sie wissen, dass völlig unterschiedliche
genetisch nicht verwandte Arten
zu demselben Merkmal gelangen oder oder ein
sehr ähnliches Aussehen entwickeln, das die
Leute denken lässt, wie Sie es wissen, bevor wir
DNA-Beziehungen hatten, als hätten
wir Arten wegen
ihres ähnlichen Aussehens in einen Topf geworfen, die
eigentlich
völlig wie nicht verwandt waren  ähnlich oder sehr
weit entfernt auf der phylogenetischen Skala,
ähm, also so, als wäre es eine Anpassung, der wir uns
annähern  das gleiche Merkmal oder wir
konvergieren zum gleichen Argument oder zum
gleichen Ort in irgendeiner Art von Raum
und das ist etwas, worüber ich
viel nachdenke, ähm,
und ich werde einfach die Quantenperspektive
mögen, wie können wir, wie Sie wissen,
alle von Ihnen gehen  Punkt a zu Punkt
wie das Durchqueren einer anderen Flugbahn,
aber wenn alles zeitlich
umkehrbar ist, ist das nicht wirklich
möglich, da wir nicht zum selben Punkt konvergieren können, als
müssten wir einem bestimmten Pfad folgen,
wenn die Zeitumkehrbarkeit
zutrifft  Das da
drin ist interessant, äh
nein, lasst uns irgendwie zu einigen unserer
früheren
Frameworks zurückkehren, aber
lustige Sachen, ich denke,
ähm,
wir wussten, dass wir die Markierung auf der Decke abdecken wollten.
Wir haben
einige der
Threads untersucht,
die die
realistische oder sogar
weitere Haltung rechtfertigen,
obwohl wir immer noch  Ich habe viele Fragen
aus den letzten 20 Minuten oder was auch immer
darüber, was jemanden führt und was
die Auswirkungen auf unterschiedliche
Haltungen, Ursachen und Folgen
verschiedener st sind  Warum ist das
für das allgemeine Studium der Kristallographie von Bedeutung? Warum ist das
für das soziale Umfeld
wie Entscheidungsfindung und Governance oder
Organisation von Bedeutung
, das im Allgemeinen eine Rechtfertigung
für die Fähigkeit der Entführung war
, mit aktiver Schlussfolgerung kompatibel zu sein
und eine Art wahrscheinlich wertvoller
Beziehung in beide Richtungen zu bilden, weil
aktiv?  Inferenz gewinnt diese kognitiven
Merkmale
, die beschrieben wurden, bevor
Basisdiagramme erfunden wurden,
analog zu Art of Blues Vorschlag,
dass es Klassifikationen gab, von denen
einige wirklich aufschlussreich waren, andere
falsche Klumpen oder Klumpen oder was auch immer,
bevor es eine Möglichkeit gab, es
anders zu betrachten
, das ist einige  Was
eine realistische Interpretation begründet, obwohl
wir uns immer noch nicht vollständig darüber im Klaren sind, was es
bedeutet, Realist zu sein oder warum es wichtig ist,
aber jetzt gehen wir zum
Konzept der pauschalen Untätigkeit
und brechen auf ähnliche Weise ihren
Blickwinkel auf die Decke
und verstehen vielleicht was  führt sie und
was ihre vorgeschlagenen Auswirkungen  sind
für diese Haltung,
was für eine Person glauben
sie zu sein, indem sie diese
kognitive soziale Position einnehmen,
die sowohl von Papieren als auch von allen ähm Redehandlungen verlangt werden könnte,
und dann ähm,
wo ist das Rindfleisch,
was ist das,
was ist das
dazwischen so  Jeder kann sich dafür entscheiden,
was man über Aktionsdecken einbringen kann
und oder wie
alles
in Hippolyta und Vanessa 21 zusammengebracht
wird  Es ist
die Zeit, die es braucht,
und dass sie stark betonen,
dass dies
als Teil dieser Ko-Konstruktion
den Menschen ermöglicht, ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen,
was
es bedeutet, sich in einer jetzt
sozialen Situation zu befinden, über die sie sprechen,
und ich bin mir nicht sicher, wo  Es steht in der
Zeitung, aber sie sprechen davon, dass
Menschen, die
neu in einem kulturellen Umfeld
sind,
einige
Zeit brauchen,
um das nicht-sprachliche,
nicht-verbale,
nicht-ausgedrückte aufnehmen zu können  in  Bildung,
die innerhalb dieses sozialen Bereichs weitergegeben wird und die
sie nicht aufgreifen,
was das ermöglicht, und
dann verbringen sie ein wenig
Zeit damit, darüber zu
sprechen,
warum das nur als eine
gemeinsame Konstruktion betrachtet werden kann  Je mehr Sie unter
dieser Bedingung tun, desto mehr
nehmen Sie auf, Sie können nicht einfach
zusehen, Sie können nicht
, tatsächlich geht der Übergang vom
Zuschauer zum
tatsächlichen Macher, und das ist eine schwere
Belastung für
die statistische
Landschaft,
weil  Sie sitzen nicht einfach da und
gehen in Ordnung, also wie groß ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass
diese Person, die ich nicht wirklich
verstehen kann, weil ich nicht einmal
Länge will, nicht einmal weiß, was sie
sagt, weil sie anders spricht
Sprache,
was ist das Problem, dass Sie nicht da
sitzen und
diese Art von Berechnungen durchführen, oder
vielleicht tun Sie es,
aber Sie sind sich dessen einfach nicht bewusst und
Sie verbringen nicht viel Zeit
mit Ihrem Taschenrechner und
versuchen, es herauszufinden  heraus, was die  was die
Verteilung ist,
während Sie versuchen,
Ihre aktive Beteiligung an dieser neuen
Sache mitzugestalten oder zu koordinieren, von der Sie jetzt
versuchen
, ein Teil davon zu sein
,
also ist das eines der Argumente, die ich
an
ihrer Zeitung im Grunde wirklich mag  Sagen
wir, damit dies funktioniert, müssen wir als erstes
anerkennen, dass es eine zeitliche
Verpflichtung gibt
, etwas in Zukunft geschehen zu lassen
, wenn Sie diese
zeitliche Verpflichtung nicht haben, wenn Sie
auschecken, bevor Sie überhaupt eingecheckt haben
, ändert sich nichts  Nichts passiert
also
aus Sicht der Markup-Pauschale,
die im Wesentlichen auf die Diskrepanzfrage zurückgeht,
ist es eine
harte Grenze, nun, Sie können es so wahrnehmen,
dass es jetzt diese Einschränkung gibt,
weil ich ihre Sprache nicht spreche
oder
Sie sich das ansehen können  es als jetzt, was ist das,
was ist diese sich entwickelnde Diskrepanz und
wie verändert sie sich, wie verändert sie sich, wie
weicht sie ab und passt sich dann wieder an
und oszilliert schließlich bis zu einer Art
Übereinstimmung
Das ist das Instrumentalstück,
ich sage nur, dass die meisten Leute nicht da
sitzen und das ausrechnen, da
es so ist,
wie es passiert, sie
versuchen im Grunde nur herauszufinden, was bedeutet, dass olay
blau etwas auf einer Aktionsdecke bringen will
Instrumentalismus und  Dann können wir uns
danach ansehen, was die inaktiven
Autoren sagen.
Ich denke, es wurde in
der pauschalen Perspektive der
Inaktivisten und Instrumentalisten gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht, das ist
immer so, wie
ich es klassisch denke, aber lassen Sie uns
Mal sehen, was die Autoren
sagen, sehen wir uns in der ersten Hälfte an, wie sie
diese Frage aufgestellt haben, und dann
enden wir mit einer Weggabelung, die
wir gut besprechen können,
damit sie mit einer
ähnlich definierenden
Decke beginnen, die wir uns ansehen könnten
Wortüberschneidung in der Zukunft, aber es ist ein
maßstabsfreies Werkzeug. Ich weiß nicht, ob maßstabsfrei
gesagt wurde, in der anderen Situation wurde
es als statistisches Werkzeug eingeführt
, das es uns ermöglicht, zu interpretieren,
und dann sehen wir wieder, dass es
inte erlaubt  In Anbetracht
dessen hat die Sprache bereits eine
gewisse Flexibilität vermittelt,
wenn man eine wohltätige,
aber enge Lesart nehmen soll,
so dass dies nicht die einzige Art zu lesen ist, sondern
nur in Bezug darauf, wie
unter der Oberfläche ein Argument
als zusätzlich
zum direkten eingerahmt wird  Rhetorik
ähm,
wir bewegen uns sofort auf die Beziehung mit der physischen Grenze im abduktiven Fall, wir sahen die
Hervorhebung
der Realität des Schließens der Handlung
und der beeinflussten Schleife,
aber es gab keine Rechtfertigung für eine
physische Grenze, und deshalb denke ich, dass
es interessant ist  frühere Diskussion
mit wie hilft uns die Multi-Agenten- oder
ähnliche agentenbasierte Modellperspektive
als wissenschaftliches Werkzeug
,
verschwommene Systeme als ähnliche Schwärme zu modellieren, die eine
bestimmte Auflösung oder Dichte entfernt sind, und
dann
direkt zur
ersten
Variante der Markov-Decke zu gehen,
wo dort  bereits aktive und
sensorische Zustände sind, anstatt
sie zunächst im allgemeinen Fall so einzuführen, dass
es um statistische Isoliermengen geht
, die ca  Dann werden
vielleicht einige Situationen so unterteilt
, dass sie einen eingehenden
repräsentierenden Sinn und dann einen ausgehenden
repräsentierenden Handlungsaspekt haben,
und das sind die pauschalen Zustände
Sinn und Handlung s und a hier und dann b
in ihrer Abbildung ist eins das Kästchen um s
und a
und  dann, ähm, das eta und das mu, sie sind
wie Flips voneinander. Ich
glaube nicht, dass das der einzige Grund ist, warum
sie diese Buchstaben sind, und sie
müssen nicht diese Buchstaben sein, die keiner von ihnen
tatsächlich sein muss  Diese Buchstaben, aber
dies ist die Verbundenheitsstruktur oder
Spärlichkeit dessen,
was
beide Autoren beschreiben.
Okay, dann ist hier die Abzweigung.
Es ist möglich, aktive
Schlussfolgerungen auf zwei Arten zu verstehen
des Modells
sollte erwartet werden, dass es als ontologische
Eigenschaft
in Punkt-Punkt-Ontologie existiert, wie
nicht
in der Verwendung der aktiven Inferenz-
Ontologie, die
wichtig genug ist
, sondern in
der Beschreibung des Phi  Losophische ontologische oder reale
Basis, deshalb wird es mit
Realismus in Verbindung gebracht.
Der zweite Weg ist die nicht-realistische
Sichtweise, dass das Modell einfach ein
instrumentelles Werkzeug ist,
also befinden
wir uns an der
Gabelung dieser beiden
Richtungen,
was der Schritt nach
meinem Verständnis ist  Film ist das,
also
macht das kein Ganzes aus, und ich
sage nicht, dass
ich im tautologischen Sinne sage, wenn wir
aktiv schlussfolgern, anstatt uns
mit einem Thema zu befassen, das den Titel aktive
Schlussfolgerung trägt,
wollen wir es nicht
einbeziehen  Die Gesamtheit der Komplexität
oder um eine Aktion
verstehen zu können, ist
eine
Art aktive Schlussfolgerung.
Meine Frage wäre, wie aktive
Schlussfolgerung tatsächlich in jedem
dieser Artikel
verwendet wird
Begründet es
das Argument, dass wir die
Theorie nicht
durch andere Köpfe vervollständigen wollen, oder sitzt es auf
dieser Art von Sahnehäubchen,
so dass es sicherstellen kann, dass wir nicht
zu
weit davon abweichen  die Schiene  Mein Argument ist, dass
es beides ist,
wenn wir aktiv auf
Blau schließen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie
Französisch in jeder Zeitung verwendet wird
Vielleicht
können wir das auch für
den Punkt lassen,
ähm,
wo ist die grafische
Zusammenfassung für all diese Zeichenfolgen, ähm
, es ist schwierig, Sachen aus dem Entführungspapier zu fischen,
weil es an
Zahlen mangelt, ähm, ich musste es finden  Meine eigenen
Zahlen für das hübsche Bild
Okay, schauen wir uns eine Schicht tiefer an,
um
die drei
Möglichkeiten, die sie vorschlagen, dass man ein
Nicht-Realist sein kann, was Markov-Decken angeht,
es wäre eine ganz andere
Kreuzungskarte mit wo ist
nicht-realistischer Anti-  Realistischer
Pro-Instrumentalist,
wir könnten einfach politische Kompasse auf der
ganzen Landkarte machen,
und
es gäbe sogar
Fragen der zweiten Ebene darüber, wie die Dinge
in welchen Zeiträumen definiert werden, und es ist einfach
alles gut,
und also versuchen wir, diesen wieder zu
folgen,
ich mag Dean  Die Art und Weise, wie Sie
es zurückgebracht haben, wie das Navigieren in
diesem kontinuierlichen Raum zwischen zwei
Farnen,
zwischen zwei Polen,
ähm,
zumindest,
und
das bleibt dann in einer Art dynamischer
Navigationsumgebung,
es ist und dann, wenn Sie die Motte sind, ist das
äh, wenn Sie können  Gehen Sie nicht zu nahe an die
Laterne, auch keine Laterne,
wenn Sie eine treffen, sterben Sie,
sodass Ihr Flug dort stoppt,
sodass ich denke, dass dies
eine sehr
aussagekräftige Interpretationsebene darstellt,
da
die Zahlen, wie bereits erwähnt, bei der Interpretation helfen
und kürzere Listen helfen, als gäbe es
drei Gründe  Warum ich dagegen bin, hier sind
sie eins, zwei und drei, das sind
wichtige Strukturen,
aber es gibt auch einen Grund, warum Menschen
außerhalb bestimmter Situationen nicht durch
Umrisse kommunizieren
Seien Sie kein Realist in Bezug auf Markov-
Decken,
was weniger
semantische Werkzeuge bedeutet.
Dies wird meiner Meinung nach sehr
interessant sein.
Sie haben keinen semantischen Wert, keinen
interpretativen
Wert,
Lingui  stic oder
anders als das konstruierte, indem
sie verwendet werden, um das Verhalten in der Situation zu verstehen oder vorherzusagen,
in der der Wissenschaftler
das Stoppschild untersucht,
könnten sie sagen, aber der statistische Vorteil
für mich bei mir
wird instrumentell verwendet
und es gäbe eine gültige Haltung,
aber insbesondere  wenn wir diese
semiotische
Sichtweise einnehmen, die der semantischen sehr ähnlich ist
und sie einen ähnlichen Samen haben, aber die
Semiose
mit dem Stoppschild und dem tatsächlichen
Stoppen und der sozialen und Aktion des
Stoppens und der Entwicklung des
Agenten, der dazu führte, dass sie diesen
Glauben daran hatten  Kontext
, der es nicht nur in
Form einer
reinen Aussagenlogik aufstellt,
auf die wir
im Punkt Null angedeutet haben, und
viele, viele der Pearson the Commons.org-
Artikel legen es viel tiefer, aber
Entführung ist nicht nur
ein statisches
Regelwerk
Der generierende Auswahlzyklus umfasst
zumindest
strukturierte Neuheiten, die sich
aus internen externen und allem
dazwischen ergeben,
und eine kontinuierliche Typaufmerksamkeit  n
Verteilung
und Strategie für Aufmerksamkeit und so weiter, also ist
es ein viel reichhaltigeres Umfeld
als potenziell
semantisch, was in bestimmten
Situationen symbolisch bedeuten kann, dh die
Art von symbolischer Logik, die
von einer Turing-Maschine ausgeführt wird, die immer noch
umfangreich sein kann, also sogar großzügig
Die Interpretation ist immer noch sehr
plausibel,
aber es gibt etwas anderes an
Semiose
und Biosemiotik, das
in dem anderen Artikel erwähnt wurde, das
nicht ein und dasselbe ist wie die
Forschermodellierung,
und das
auch von Yellow Burnberg in dem Artikel von 2016
zum antizipierenden Gehirn gut untersucht wurde  ist kein
Wissenschaftler
, der eine wissenschaftliche Analysemodalität
mit
dem kognitiven System als Erkenner kontrastiert
und die Kognitionswissenschaft in gewisser
Weise davon durch ökologische
Psychologie unterscheidet, Dekan.
Ja, ich wollte das gerade
anhängen, denke ich, damit
dies geschieht, denke ich  Theoretisch ist es
einfach zu sagen,
ähm,
wir warten nicht auf unsere Priors,
ich bleibe einfach nicht Objecti
Ich habe all das durchgemacht, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass die meisten von uns
sich der Prioritäten
und Gewichtungen bewusst sind, die wir
sogar unterbewusst angewendet haben, selbst wenn wir diese wirklich strenge wissenschaftliche Haltung einnehmen,
also
denke ich, dass
Sie sagen können,
ähm,
es gibt  Nein, das hat keinen Mehrwert,
ich bin nur, ich bin nur, ich habe mich
davon entfernt, und ich bin nur ein passiver
Beobachter,
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie lange wir passiv bleiben,
bevor wir anfangen,
Gewichte anzuwenden und  Werte zu dem, was
wir
analysieren, besonders in einer Situation,
besonders in Situationsanalysen,
die persönlich sind und die Konsequenzen
auf uns zurückfallen und jetzt, wenn Sie nur
etwas beobachten und es keine
Konsequenzen für Sie als Beobachter gibt
Vielleicht ist das einfacher, aber wenn Sie
an einen Ort kommen, an
dem der Wissenschaftler Teil des
Experiments ist,
wow,
zeigen Sie mir, wie
dieser Schalter ausgeschaltet wird und Sie
kein Gewicht auf etwas
sehr
Mächtiges und Wahres legen und in vielerlei Hinsicht
implizit und  e  Bei
der Art von Botschaften, die ich manchmal
in der Informationsumgebung sehe, geht
es ausdrücklich darum, Menschen dazu zu bringen, ihre Vorgeschichte zu aktualisieren, um
zu glauben, dass sie
in ein größeres Problem einbezogen sind,
das eine absolut gültige
Kommunikation und Perspektive
und das
Wie des Pfades
und der Homöostase und ist  das Mehrebenensystem
und der kritische Weg, dem es
folgen muss,
einschließlich Reflexivität und Erzählung und
Antizipation
und dieser Bottom-up-Top-down-
Aspekt
, das ist soziale Untätigkeit,
wie Menschen argumentieren können, dass es
in verschiedenen Umgebungen unterschiedliche soziale Strukturen gibt,
und das tut es nicht.  Es muss kein Oben-Unten sein,
es muss im Grunde keine spezifische
Metapher oder psychoanalytische wie
Linse sein,
aber die einzige Abkürzung, um
all diese Komplexität
in
einen
Datenpunkt zu kollabieren, ist dieser eine Trick
,
es wie ein Experiment anzugehen
Denn darum geht es bei dem Experiment
in gewisser Weise darum, einen Verteiler zu finden,
bei dem es so ist, als hätte diese Röhre diesen
DNA-Strang und diesen  eine Reihe von Dingen,
und dann können die
Farbe an der Wand und all diese anderen
Faktoren des wahren
Kontexts davon
isoliert werden, das ist so etwas wie die
teilweise Informationskapselung
oder einfach jede andere Art von System,
und dann sehen wir möglicherweise wie mit
Quanten,
ja,
einige  hartnäckige Anomalien
, die darauf hindeuten, dass die Dinge nicht immer so waren, wie
sie schienen,
aber die eigentliche Fallstudie ist nicht die
Quantenmechanik, sondern die bayessche
Mechanik
mit der psychologischen Studie
und der Neuroimaging-Studie und der
Verhaltensstudie
durch
alle Arten von Menschen
in allen sozialen und Handlungsumgebungen
und
[Musik]
, die wirklich auf einige
der tieferen Implikationen der
formalen Modellierung sozialer und kognitiver
Systeme des Interaktionismus hinweist,
man könnte
aus diesem realen Leben heraustreten
und in ein anderes
eintreten und sich aus der
Perspektive einer dritten Person positionieren
und darauf
zurückblicken  Einzelpfadebene
und sehe das als Experimentator
und das ist in vielerlei Hinsicht mit
Meta verbunden  erkenntnis
aber
kann dieser beobachter
behaupten realismus
versus instrumentalismus
woher sprechen die leute in
bezug
auf diese sichtweise ich weiß nicht ich spreche nur diese
art wie bist du
wo
bist du an und das bezieht sich wirklich auf das
selbstkonzept von  blue brachte und mag
die Art von Situiertheit mit dem
Selbstkonzept und dann realistischem Instrumentalisten,
aber lassen Sie uns durch diese Punkte weitergehen,
zweiter Grund, warum man ein
Nicht-Realist in Bezug auf Markup-Decken sein
könnte, man könnte sie lediglich als wertvolle Fiktionen ansehen,
ja okay, die Abstraktion erlauben  Bestimmte
Merkmale eines Phänomens,
aber eine wertvolle Fiktion, die
man fragen könnte, ob alle generierten
Interpretationen
wertvoll sind oder nicht,
oder auch zu
sagen, dass es eine Fiktion ist, und zu sagen, dass
alles eine Fiktion
ist, ist, dass ähm,
auf welche Weise ist das instrumentell oder auf
welche Weise ist das  Realist
, der eine echte Behauptung aufstellt, dass das der
Stoff ist, aus dem alle Dinge sind,
obwohl es nicht der Stoff ist, der
möglicherweise jemandem über Atome beigebracht wurde
in einem bestimmten Klassenzimmer,
so dass die anhaltende Divergenz dazu führen kann, dass
einige denken, dass einer davon
wissenschaftlich fundiert und ein anderer
metaphysisch fundiert ist
und oder offen für Präferenzglauben
oder andere
Vorlieben und Bedenken, die in diese Diskussion eintreten,
und dann ähm, okay, die dritte ist, dass
Sie könnten  Seien Sie kein Realist in Bezug auf Markov-
Decke,
denn
nur weil der Erfolg der
Verwendung der Markup-Decke
die Akzeptanz des
epistemischen Werts des Modells rechtfertigt,
ohne unbedingt ontologische
Ansprüche
zu stellen, mit anderen Worten,
nur weil das Epizyklusmodell
gut passt,
tut dies nicht  Das heißt, es ist wirklich ein Epizyklus,
nur weil das kreisförmige Umlaufbahnmodell
gut zu 99 passt,
bis jemand daherkommt und 99,9
mit einer völlig anderen Modellstruktur geht,
also ist es so, als würde man sagen,
wie sicher Sie sich über eine realistische
Interpretation der Struktur von sein könnten  das
Modell,
wenn sie
als Teil der Verpflichtung zum
wissenschaftlichen Prozess die Tür verlassen könnten
offen
für ein zukünftiges Modell mit höherer
Erklärungskraft, Design und
Kontrolle usw. Dean,
ja, das ist und ich weiß nicht, wo es ist
, wir hatten es tatsächlich, weil ich
mir heute Morgen die Folien von 47-0 angeschaut habe
und da ist  a Es gibt einen Teil
, der in der anderen Zeitung hervorgehoben wird,
die Gespräche, in denen Pierce sagt, lass die
Tür offen, darum geht es bei Entführungen.
Es ist einfach, dass die Tür ein Glas ist
Hypothese ist keine Erklärung für die beste
oder nicht
etwas, eher die beste Erklärung,
aber Sie können jetzt etwas
haben, von
dem Sie sich lösen können, und das liegt daran, dass
die Tür offen gelassen wurde, damit Sie wieder darauf zugreifen
können  zu dieser Schlussfolgerung, dass der
dritte der Erfolg der Markov-
Decke durch die instrumentalistische Linse,
aber es gibt Leute auf der realistischen Seite
, die dasselbe sagen, je
offener,
desto wahrscheinlicher ist es, dass Sie '  Ich
komme früher zu
den Einzelheiten,
hier ist eine lustige
Ameisenbeispiel-Analogie, um es irgendwie
auf Stevens frühere Anfrage zurückzubringen. Ähm, es
gibt schneller ist langsamer oder langsamer ist
schneller.
Man kann sich beides vorstellen, aber der
empirische Befund bei Ameisen ist das während
Bestimmte
Fluchtevakuierungssituationen wie das Verlassen eines
Raums, in dem Alarmpheromon
verbreitet wurden
, wenn es wie eine Verengung in
den Ausgängen gibt, so dass die Morphologie des Nestes
, das sie gebaut haben,
wenn es eine Verengung gibt
, die Situation in Autostaus und
in
Situationen von Menschenansammlungen kann  sehr tödlich sein
und mit
einer
Quetschsituation oder einer Flüssigkeit bis fest
wie eingeklemmt und dann mit einem Bruch verbunden sein, der
alle möglichen
Probleme in der Mitte haben kann, wo es passiert,
während die Ameisen ihre
individuellen Bewegungen verlangsamen
Es war also nicht wie eine geordnete Warteschlange
, in der sich alle anstellen, und jetzt werden wir
darauf warten, dass die Nummer so und so
aufgerufen wird,
das war
ihre Antwort  Se in der
Situation der Biosemiotik
und der Nischenkonstruktion des Fluchtrechts
war eine langsamere schnellere Reaktion,
so dass ja ihre Morphologie als
Nestkameraden ihnen hilft, indem sie weiße Beine haben
,
sie sind physisch
isolierend, also ist das nicht zu sagen  Das
ist das einzige,
was ein Mensch
in einer physischen Fluchtumgebung semantisch im Auge behalten muss,
aber aktive Schlussfolgerungen
lassen uns zu
diesen anderen Umgebungen zurückkehren
und die Ameisen
und ihre Sicht aus dem Inneren der
Endosymbiose betrachten, wie die
Pheromonwahrnehmung die Neurobiologie der
Nestkamerad und dann ist da noch die Exosymbiose
mit dem Wissenschaftler
und dann
gibt es
Instrumente im Play
Dean,
also denkst du nicht durch Ameisenköpfe
, die ttam statt ttym wären,
aber
es gibt das Gefühl,
dass sogar ein Hive-Verstand am
Werk ist  obwohl man diesen versteckgedanken nicht unbedingt
teilen kann
,
gibt es keine mischung, es gibt
eine autonomie
und es gibt ein gefühl, dass,
wenn ich
an das top-d glaube  eigene Version, die
durch einen Aktivismus ermöglicht wird,
wenn ich daran glaube, dass ich auch
verstehen kann,
ohne durch den Verstand eines Realisten zu denken,
was diese realistische
Perspektive ist,
also
bist du nicht
wir sind wir nicht ich würde ich würde  sagen,
dass das, was thomas und inez geschrieben haben,
aus logischer sicht
sehr viel sinn macht,
aber das disqualifiziert
mich nicht mein mein denken
und dieses andere denken
vom koexistieren
und und und haben ich glaube nicht ich weiß nicht
Wenn die Antwort Daniel beobachtet oder
nicht, vielleicht sind sie es, ich meine, vielleicht gibt es eine
andere Erzählung, die Daniel mit uns teilen wird
, darüber, wann die
Ameisen auf ihn aufmerksam wurden, aber ich
erzähle Ihnen nur eine kurze Geschichte, ich
füttere Elstern, ich füttere Orbits
und was die Rabenvögel  Ich habe erkannt, dass ich
es bin, weil sie Gesichter sehr schnell
erkennen,
und was sie tun, ist, dass sie den Gefallen erwidern, den
ich
bekomme  rock, dass ich
den Hund f  Gut, weil sie
dieses Hundefutter mit Fischgeschmack lieben, geben sie
tatsächlich Dinge zurück und leisten einen Beitrag,
weil sie wollen,
dass ich diesen Zyklus fortsetze, also weiß ich nicht, ob Ameisen das
tun, aber ich weiß, dass andere Arten
es so beschreiben würden
Da ich weiß, dass mein Verstand
mein Verhalten sicherlich
von einem strategischen Standpunkt aus beeinflussen will,
gibt es viele tolle Punkte
, das steht
im Gegensatz zu einem
Rahmen wie Pan-Psychismus oder wie
die Abwesenheit von Psychismus, also lass einfach
viele dieser Fragen, die
du beschrieben hast, wie ein Pan-  absichtliche
Haltung ist
eine pan-Strategie
, die ein komplexes Holobionten-Blues-
Mikrobiom
sowie die Einstellung der Krähen-Lieferkette von Menschen und Hunden zulässt, die es
ermöglichen, dass diese
existieren und durch eine ähnliche
Entscheidungsfindung, Kontrolltheorie, Spieltheorie usw. modelliert werden,
aufgrund des Pragmatismus des Spiels
, wie es ist  ein Tor dazu,
all diese Situationen
als etwas zu betrachten, um einige Spiele zu spielen,
um durch einige Spiele zu signalisieren, auf
diese Weise zu gewinnen oder th zu haben  Das ist das Ergebnis
, das ist ziemlich äh interessant,
dann
ähm, über
andere Arten nachzudenken, das ist eine sehr interessante
Idee, und es wäre cool,
Erfahrungen wie durch Spiele oder Kunst zu entwerfen
, die verschiedene Arten der Kommunikation ermöglichen könnten,
und dann
auf den Punkt in dem abduktiven Artikel
darüber  die ökonomie der wissenschaft, die wir
zu dieser diskussion von pearsons konzept zurückbringen können,
es ist, als würde man durch die gedanken der rezensenten denken
und also auch nur facetten sehen
oder durch die gedanken meines gegners
denken, es ist keine vollständige emulation
[musik]
, sondern nur
die fähigkeit, schnittstellenangebote zu generieren  Politik
gibt es so viel
in einer partiellen Informationssituation
, die die Entität generieren muss,
und der Generierungsumfang bedeutet, dass
es auch einen starken Auswahlmechanismus geben muss
, und das sind die Zyklen
der
zeitlichen
Abduktionslogik,
die uns
aus
der induktiven, deduktiven,
statischen, konzeptuellen
Dialektik herausbrechen
und das bringt Pragmatismus, Aktion,
ökologische Psychologie und so weiter
Es ist wirklich faszinierend zu sehen, was
in diesem Raum
formaler Modelle der Wahrnehmung, des Erkennens
und des Handelns fließt,
die Tausende von Jahren alt sind, und es
wird wichtig sein, so viele dieser verschiedenen Fäden zu verstehen,
weil sie nicht alle quantitativ sind
und äh das abduktive Papier und  Das
Social and Active Paper
zeigt zwei der wichtigsten
Bereiche, in denen das der Fall ist. Dean.
Ja, fahren Sie einfach ganz schnell fort,
also wäre es egal, ob ich mich entschieden habe,
eine Situationsanalyse zu
machen und diese darauf aufzubauen  eine sehr reale
Schenkungsübung, die im Gange ist, oder
zumindest interpretiere ich sie als eine
Schenkungsübung, die ein Ansatz wäre, den
ich wählen könnte, der andere Ansatz, den ich wählen könnte
, wäre ein sehr instrumentalistischer
in Bezug auf den Token-Tausch
Die Dinge
würden funktionieren, wenn sie zusammengefügt werden,
könnten
noch additiver sein. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob
es verwirrend wäre. Ich denke, es würde
nur zwei Linsen
auf dem
SA bieten  Ich befinde mich
im selben
Prozess
und betrachte die Abbildungen zwei und drei von Hippolyta und Vanessa.
Hier ist also
eine Perspektive auf die soziale
Konstruktion
, die sie aus
nicht-inaktivistischen oder nicht-aktiven Schlussfolgerungsperspektiven ziehen.
Der Unterschied zu Abbildung 3 ist die
soziale Aktion in Abbildung 2  Unter dem
aktiven Inferenzrahmen
befindet sich die Kopplung
und daher
scheint es nicht einmal
eine Art von Ding zu geben
, die von diesem grauen Kästchen
in der Mitte von Abbildung 3 erfasst würde. Gehen Sie
also auf
Nummer sicher und
nehmen Sie eine instrumentalistische Perspektive auf
dieses graue Kästchen
Es ist
ein sehr wichtiger Knoten und eine sehr wichtige
Interpretation,
und dann geben Sie das, was Sie wissen, durch die
Röhren
an den abduktiven Rezensenten weiter,
der es sich ansieht und ja sagt, und die
sozialen Akteure beteiligen sich an abduktiver
Logik
zeitdynamik und der fluss der aktion
mit der umgebung
aus pierces arbeit
entführung
können in einem realistischen rahmen interpretiert werden,
so dass diese ca  n mit diesem Auge instrumental gehalten werden
und man kann sich dann fragen, ob die
Abduktion
, die Sie dabei abduktiv modellieren,
vielleicht sogar eine instrumentelle Haltung einnehmen kann,
aber für den sozialen
Akteur eher instrumentell für die Endosemiosis ist
Aus dem Axosemiose-Blau,
also hast du mir die Worte direkt aus dem
Mund genommen, gute Arbeit, ähm, so wie
diese graue Box ist diese
soziokulturelle Bedeutung und modellbasierte
Argumentation wie können diese
unter
Exosemiose subsumiert werden? Fragst
du, ob es eine sein kann  Filter
wie ist Exosemiose
wie
die Zuschreibung soziokultureller Bedeutungen
und modellbasierter Argumentation ist, dass
Exosamiose
aus den Definitionen, die ich in
den Verwendungen gesehen habe, die ich gesehen habe, Exo bedeutet
von außen Endo bedeutet Einsicht im
Allgemeinen in wissenschaftlichen Wörtern Semiose ist
das  also aufbauprozess
also
exosymbiose ist ein blick von aussen
z.b.
auf diese stoppschildsituation zu schauen entfaltet sich auf diese
ameisenpheromonsituation zu schauen unf  alt,
während die Endosemiose der
interpretative semiotische Prozess ist,
durch den etwas eine
interne
Bedeutung erhält,
die dann gefragt werden könnte, ob es sich um
eine symbolische oder kognitive oder eine
Aufmerksamkeitsart handelt, und all diese verschiedenen
Aspekte, aber
ich hoffe, dass dies sowieso eine genaue
Unterscheidung ist  du eigentlich bist du du bei
ich versuche das
für mein kleines gehirn einfach zu machen fragst du
ob eine person die
perspektive der dritten person einnehmen kann oder nicht
also versuche ich einfach zu verstehen
wie endosemiose mir sehr
klar ist
ähm
aber  wie diese exo semiose wie
wenn ich es gerne nachschaue genau richtig so
ähm
Endosemiose ist wie die
Signalübertragung ins Innere das ist
wie Endosymbiose wie das
ähm
richtig wie die Deutung von
Zeichen ins Innere aber so ist
Exosymbiose wie zwischen
Organismen  wie die Zeicheninterpretation
und Signalübertragung zwischen
Organismen der gleichen Art oder
verschiedener Arten wie zum Beispiel der
a  Nicht Pheromon wie das ist, was ich als Exosus gelesen
habe. Wenn Sie sich also diese Abbildung drei ansehen,
ist das nicht Exosus.
Ich meine, es sieht aus wie eine
Modelldarstellung und was war das
andere Ding darin, also suche ich nach
dem
Hier ist eine lustige Ansicht, denke ich  Zum Exo, also
ja, ich denke, wir sind uns hier einig, dass
Endosomose wie die Signalisierung innerhalb
des Organismus oder die Sicht von innen ist,
aber
genau dort ist auch das Herzstück
der Grenze als Physische versus
Grenze als Funktion, also
gibt es ein Ganzes
Komplexität mit Biosemiotik, was
normalerweise meiner Meinung nach der Grund ist, warum Leute über die Biosemiotik sprechen
und die Komplexität einfach erkennen,
anstatt zu früh eine Position
zu dieser Unterteilung einzunehmen, aber dann ist
dies die exosomatische Perspektive,
die Nachrichten an angebliche Außerirdische konstruiert,
also wenn wir suchen, wer  sind die Autoren
, die die Autoren dieses Papiers sind,
sie sind hier aufgeführt, Douglas, ein Trainer,
aber ja, lasst uns ähm,
also so, nur so etwas wie soziokulturelle
Bedeutungszuschreibung und und  wie in dem
meme paper, das ähm daniel und ich gerade
herausgebracht haben und in
ähm
mit rj und marijua ähm
diese semiotische darstellung ist
kulturell
wie
relativ, ich meine, wie es kein stoppschild gibt,
wird kein stoppschild sein, um
jemanden zu mögen, der mag  Die Ureinwohner
mögen sehr wie einheimische Primitiven, ähm
wie Lebensstil, richtig,
also ist
dieses Exo-Exosymbiotikum wie eine
Übertragung zwischen
Organismen der gleichen Art, aber
auch wie die gleiche Kultur, würde ich sagen,
weil wie, wie kannst du es nicht
mögen
und sogar ich nicht '  Ich weiß nicht, ob das auf Pheromone zutrifft,
wie wenn Pheromone und
verschiedene Ameisenarten
verschiedene Dinge bedeuten, wie das gleiche
Pheromon mehr als eine Bedeutung haben kann,
ist das auch wahr
oder die gleiche Art von molekularer
Verbindung. Ich meine, ich denke, wir
wissen wahrscheinlich nicht genug
Ich denke, ich glaube, ich verstehe, was Sie
jetzt fragen
, ob es einen angenommenen
Sinn
gibt, dass
irgendeine Art von Verstrickung vorhanden sein
muss,
damit irgendetwas davon Sinn macht, um Sinn zu
machen  Lügen, dass etwas existiert hat
,
das in der Vergangenheit vielleicht nicht existiert hat, in der fernen Vergangenheit
würde es in einem anderen Kontext
nicht existieren, deshalb die soziokulturellen
Bedeutungen wie wie ich denke, dass dies als
wie exo
exosimiosis gemeint ist  Es versteht sich von selbst, dass
es einfach unterschiedliche
Nähe entlang verschiedener Achsen gibt, z.
B. Menschen, die dieselbe
Sprache, aber unterschiedliche
Vokabeln sprechen, oder
Sie wissen
, dass die Körpersprache so wichtig ist, je
weiter entfernt oder unterschiedlich die kognitive
Struktur im
Verhältnis zu dem ist, was
sie wird  schwieriger zu zitieren, versetzen Sie sich
in ihre Lage
und so weiter,
und ich denke, das ist eine
große Frage bei den Multiskalensystemphänomenen,
ob sie dissipativ
oder persistent sind,
verschiedene Intelligenzen, die
verstehen, was das Wasser ist, in dem wir schwimmen
, kognitiv und sprachlich,
weil das Wasser  wir schwimmen darin, ein Teil
davon wird das Signal
für etwas anderes sein,
es könnte das Einflusssignal sein,
wie die b-Matrix in Acti  Die Beeinflussung
kausaler Zusammenhänge in der Welt
als Teil des Wassers, in dem Sie darin schwimmen
, könnte auch eine Art
Modifikation durch Stigmatisierung sein, eine Nischenmodifikation
wie Ihre physischen Einflüsse, die
das Wasser sein können, in dem Sie schwimmen, in dem
Sinne, dass Sie sie nicht bemerken wie viele andere
Dinge  kommen Sie von und durch uns haben
wir kein direktes Bewusstsein dafür,
also sind sie wie die Farbe an den Wänden
in diesem PCR-
Experiment mit der Amplifikation der DNA,
weil es die Teile sind, die, ob wir
wollen oder
nicht, zu einem Punkt verdichtet werden
oder  Ein Pfad
und dann wird das zu unserem Sinn,
indem wir aus lokalen Teilinformationen machen,
als ob wir einen Großteil des unsichtbaren Teils
einfach ignorieren könnten, und wir tun
kognitiv so, wie wir darüber gesprochen haben, wie
die Abgaswärme mit Chris-Feldern und
Quanten, als müssten Sie
Informationen verbrennen  Passen Sie auf
und deshalb müssen Sie darauf
achten, sich mit einer wirklich komplexen
Nische auseinanderzusetzen,
also gibt es viele
Spannungen
auf diesem
Weg
und
besonders mit dieser Dyade, und da bin ich mir
sicher  viel andere verwandte Arbeit, aber mit
dieser Dyade
und ich denke, mit der Linse, mit der
Sie sich Dean näherten
, werden einige dieser
Fäden in ein anderes Licht
gerückt, und insbesondere für diejenigen, die auf diese semiotische Weise eine bayesische Überraschung in einem
kognitiven Zustand hatten  Aktualisierung
von einer beliebigen Anzahl verschiedener Dinge
, die wie Proof of Concept
soziale Untätigkeit sind,
aber nicht in einer
korrodierten oder in einer Performance-Kunst,
obwohl wer sagen könnte, dass es keine
Performance-Kunst ist, aber immer noch ein Weg,
der den Realismus
durch die formalen und anderen Türen in das Soziale bringt,
äh  dean und dann blue
ich denke ich würde diese beiden
papiere als säulen sehen ich sehe sie
aus verschiedenen gründen als wirklich stabilisierend
und ich würde lieber auf beiden füßen stehen
und etwas stabiles unter beiden
haben und versuchen darauf zu stehen  einen oder
beide Füße auf
einem Zylinder stehen zu haben, weil ich finde, dass
ich das aufgrund meiner Form schwieriger finde,
aber
als wir versuchten, diese neue
Saison mit Live-Streams aufzunehmen  Als ich zwei Papiere
zusammenbrachte, fühlte es sich wie ein Grenzmoment an
,
und ich denke, eines der Dinge, die
wir hoffentlich vermittelt haben, ist, dass
es von Natur aus komplizierter ist, zwei Dinge gleichzeitig zu betrachten,
nicht unbedingt komplex, die Komplexität
besteht in jedem der Papiere, aber
zwei dinge gleichzeitig zu betrachten
ist komplizierter und daher
voller
fehler der Trial-and-Error-
Beziehung. Ich sage nicht, dass
wir viele Fehler gemacht haben, aber ich denke,
der erste ist
die erste Generationsregel
du wirst es nicht sofort bekommen,
du wirst wieder diese zeitliche Verpflichtung haben müssen,
um in der Lage zu sein, dorthin zu gelangen,
wo zum Teufel du denkst, dass du gehst,
und ich wusste nicht wirklich, wohin das führen
würde, außer
ich  Ich frage mich, was passiert, wenn
wir unser Aufmerksamkeitsregime
nicht einschränken. Ich wusste nicht unbedingt, dass wir es erweitern
, aber ich wusste, dass
wir irgendwann die Autoren dazu bringen könnten, uns zu
fragen,
warum wir diese beiden auswählen, ich nicht  denke es h
Da es sich zwangsläufig um diese beiden Papiere handelt, ist es
nur so, dass
beide Papiere
eine schöne Symphonie erzeugen und kreieren,
also
könnte es sich um ein beliebiges Set von Papieren
handeln, die ein Chocolatier
oder ein Weinkenner braucht, um die Paarung wirklich zu etwas
Besonderem zu machen,
aber es gibt andere
Situationen, in denen eine Paarung möglich ist  kann
potenziell fruchtbar und aufschlussreich sein, wie
manchmal denke ich darüber in einem
Community-Kontext, dass Sie immer
zwischen null und einem Kontext teilen werden,
und wo immer Sie in diesem Kontinuum sind,
die Teile, in denen Sie teilen, sind
großartig und die Teile, in denen Sie
anders können wir auch respektieren wie toll
oder die überschneidung zwischen zwei papieren wow
der wortgebrauch war gegensätzlich
oder es war irgendwie gegensätzlich
ok
und dann bei der haltung so dann
dachte ich ähm was
für
spiele wo die leute haben  Auf einer
einzigen Stange
an einem tropisch schönen Ort zu stehen
und zu versuchen, nicht zu fallen, dachte ich, wenn
Sie beide Füße, wie Sie sagten, auf einer
Position haben,
schmale
dann
Buffets des Gewinns  Das sind Angriffe auf Ihren
stabilen Nicht-Gleichgewichtszustand,
besonders wenn es so ist, dass eine
dieser Personen
Professor wird,
nur als Beispiel,
also warum nicht
widerstehen
und zu einem festen Modus zurückkehren,
denn das ist so etwas wie der Modus, der das
sucht  Wir haben in einigen der
jüngsten Arbeiten von Dalton und Maxwell davon gehört, dass
der feste Modus der Schwerpunkt ist,
und dann eine andere Art, die Sie
mit einer Art Divergenz ungleich Null beschreiben,
und der Raum dazwischen ist wie
im
Basketball die Haltung der dreifachen Bedrohung,
weil  Sie könnten dribbeln oder passen oder
vorbeischießen,
als würden Sie zum Korb gehen,
und äh ja, das ist eine andere Haltung
und es ist auch in einem Feld von Angeboten,
also ist es nicht nur so, dass sie in einer
anderen Position sind, als wären die Füße
hier nicht viel breiter als die  Füße hier,
aber das ist die Ermittlungsstimmung,
da Pierce
vielleicht darauf angespielt hätte,
dass in einem Kontext
mit einer Aktion ökologische Psychologie
all das in einem Kontext
mit einem Instrument
und einem Spiel
und som  Alles außerhalb des Spiels,
das das Spiel unterstützt hat,
all diese Levels
sind in der dreifachen Bedrohung, aber das Wie bin
ich hierher gekommen,
warum bin ich auf dem Grünen,
ist ein begrenzter Kontext
und
ähm,
ja, es ist immer noch hochqualifiziert, niemand
fragt,
wie viel Energie fließt  das zu
tun, das ist harte Arbeit,
und es gibt eine riesige Belohnung dafür, es
gut zu machen,
und es gibt viele, und deshalb
stimme ich voll und ganz zu und hatte nicht einmal die Absicht
, dass die Leute viel dafür hätten trainieren können,
das könnte jemand sein, der es
tut.  Ich spiele nicht Basketball
und deshalb muss es ein wenig
dynamisch und situativ sein, aber
wenn man sie nur als eine Art extreme Weise
der Papierinterpretation in einer
erweiterten Papierinterpretationsmetapher betrachtet,
könnte man
verschiedene Arten sehen
,
Semiose aus Literatur
oder Diskurs zu erhalten
und
was dann  ist die Rolle der Teilnahme
und des Feedbacks und dann diese Multi-Agent-
Einstellung, die wir erwähnt haben.
Hoffentlich ist das nicht zu
zufällig  ne art paarung von papieren,
die ich gerne gemacht hätte, ist dieses
abduktive argumentationspapier mit
dem chris fields quantenpapier das
aus den 40er jahren.
like, weil ich gerade
so sehr daran erinnert wurde, als ich das
papier durchgelesen habe
und  Genau wie beim Lernen über abduktives
Denken und wie sieht das aus
und wie wissen wir, dass Sie beim
abduktiven Denken keine
vollständigen Informationen haben, es ist wie teilweise
beobachtbar, und so machen Sie einfach
Ihre beste Vorhersage aus einer teilweisen
Beobachtung und es wurde gemacht  Ich denke an
die überlappenden Quantenreferenzrahmen, bei
denen Sie es nicht mögen, als ob Sie
keine vollständige Überlappung mit dem Quantenreferenzrahmen eines anderen erreichen können, als
ob es
nicht so wäre, dass es selbst bei perfektem Lernen
immer noch etwas Rauschen
oder Überlappung geben wird  zwischen der
Quantenreferenz oder einer
Inkongruenz zwischen den
Quantenreferenzrahmen ein Bereich
, der sich nicht überschneidet, also weiß ich nicht,
dass ich nur diese beiden Dinge bin, die das sind
Es ist wie eine Paarung, die
ich gerne gesehen hätte,
das ist das, was wirklich interessant ist,
wie früher angedeutet, das Quantum hat
das Glas
bei der Reflexivitätsfrage
[Musik]
in der Wissenschaftsphilosophie zerbrochen. Ich hoffe, das ist
nicht zu
übertrieben, um es zu sagen, und das war es nicht  Das einzige
Stück im Gebäude oder die
Schwächung des Glases, aber die
zuvor erwähnte anhaltende Anomalie in
Bezug auf den experimentellen Kontext
erweiterten den Umfang bestimmter Fragen
in der Wissenschaft
über den
Diskurs in bestimmten kulturellen Kreisen
während der letzten etwa 500 Jahre hinaus, in denen
Stephen auf Teile von so viel Quantität
anspielte  wo diese
abduktive zeitliche
Relationalität da ist, wenn Sie es jetzt sehen, ist es kein
protoaktives Teilchen. Oh, wenn das
Elektron nur ein Kieselstein
wäre, würde dies nicht passieren,
oder
wenn das Elektron ein Kieselstein wäre, der
größer wäre, würde das nicht passieren,
aber nicht  passieren oder würde es
nicht passieren, weil wir
es besser messen könnten,
all diese Fragen über
Punkte und Teilchen und wa
Unter der bayesschen Mechanik
als Mechanik für kognitive Partikel kann
die Reflexivität jetzt nicht nur
aus der
Elektronenskala einfließen,
sondern ich habe das Gefühl, dass es mehrere
Kontaktdienste
mit Reflexivität
bei der semiotischen
Erzählung gibt,
die die realen Skalen
außerhalb des Experiments ökologisch sind,
und ich denke, das ist was  teilweise
spricht
die Art und Weise an, wie wir in diese Diskussion eingetreten sind
,
also ähm, in unseren letzten
fünf oder zehn Minuten,
was möchten wir
haben oder 4.2 nur an die Autoren anmerken, ob
sie sich das
in der Zeit zwischendurch anhören oder nicht, wir suchen
Ich freue mich darauf, mit allen zu sprechen, die es wollen
, sei es für Punkt 2 oder zu irgendeinem
Zeitpunkt in der Zukunft, es gibt immer ein
Angebot für Punkt 3, also hoffen wir, diese
Diskussion mit denen fortzusetzen, die geschrieben haben,
und denen, die noch nicht geschrieben haben,
weil es so viel zu tun gibt
Bauen Sie auf diesem Vektor auf, also
fühlen Sie sich beide frei, so lange Sie
möchten,
einfach alle Punkte zu erwähnen, die Sie
für die nächste Woche besprechen möchten, die
Dekan um mitgebracht hat  Früher wie
Wo ist aktive Inferenz Ist es
die Basis Ist es wie darauf zu ruhen Gibt
es da eine Art Dualität? Ich
denke, das ist etwas, das ich gerne
auf jedes Papier zurückblicken und
herausfinden möchte  Wo möchte ich
aktive Inferenz in diese Säule oder auf
diese Säule setzen
oder ist es die Säule, die ich nicht weiß
?
Kennen Sie diese Klausel, ja, diesen Absatz
mit diesem Papier
oder diese Interaktion des Papiers,
dieses Tool, das von dem Papier entwickelt wurde,
wo würde man versuchen, hervorzuheben,
wie ich das Papier gesehen habe
? Dekan, weil ich weiß, dass Stephen Luke vollkommen zustimmen
würde  hinter wo in Klammern, wenn
sein Akt der Schlussfolgerung,
weil ich denke, dass das so wichtig ist,
wenn wir über abduktive
Logik
und Retroduktion sprechen, die andere Sache ist,
dass
i i i
i hoffe, dass dieser Blaue gut
denkt
Ich
hoffe, das ist eine Öffnung,
und ich werde sagen, dass
es eine unglaubliche Menge an
Vorbereitung erfordert, zwei Papiere zusammenzuziehen,
ohne den angemessenen Respekt für die Menge an
Arbeit zu zeigen, die das ist
Die Autoren und Urheber dieser Arbeit
haben dies
getan, was auch immer die
Vorbereitung in Bezug auf die Quantifizierung für eine
einzelne Arbeit ist, um ihr
gerecht zu werden,
es ist ein Vielfaches davon, zwei Arbeiten zu zitieren
, aber ich denke,
wenn wir aktiv werden, folgert das
nicht nur  Fachexperten zur
aktiven Schlussfolgerung
, dass diese Übung, so schwierig und
zeitaufwändig sie auch ist
, buchstäblich das
Spiel verändert, weil wir heute hier ziemlich viel über das Spiel gesprochen haben, von dem
ich wiederum
nicht dachte, dass es auftauchen würde,
aber  Gott sei Dank,
weil es nicht gegensätzlich ist, kann das Spiel
sein,
jeder steigt ins Kanu
und arbeitet zusammen, um zu den
hawaiianischen Inseln zu gelangen, die
buchstäblich das Spiel sein können  Richtig,
es muss kein
Wettbewerb sein,
es ist kein Rennen, es ist, ob wir überleben
angesichts der begrenzten Menge an Informationen
, die wir hier sammeln müssen,
da sie
für unsere Fähigkeit, weiterzumachen, genauso wichtig sind.
Ich denke, das ist es, was eine aktive Schlussfolgerung
ausmacht  Das
ist der Übergang von einem
Fachexperten zu einem Experten für Vorhersagen,
also
möchte ich den Leuten noch einmal dafür danken,
dass es sich anfühlt, als würde man
sich auf wirklich riskante Weise
da draußen aufhängen, weil es riskant ist, das ist es,
danke
nochmal, es gibt so viel  Zu sagen, ich hoffe,
es ist eine Ehre und ein Privileg
, in epistemischen Räumen zu sein
und seine ähm homöostatischen Variablen
gesichert zu haben, so dass sich ein erstaunlicher
Raum öffnet und sich
dem zeitlichen Aspekt der Entführung nähert,
klingt so großartig, zu ihm zurückzukehren,
weil ich denke, ein anderer davon  Diese
Berührungspunkte Kommunikation
ist die Dynamik Was die einzigen
Formalismen in beiden Papieren in Bezug auf
ähnliche Gleichungen und mathematische Symbole waren
, waren drei Darstellungen von
Dyna  mische Systeme
von Hipolito und Vanness
, um einen Kontaktpunkt zu verbinden und zu erden
, von dem aus
sie eine Haltung und eine geschickte
Leistung
in
die mathematische symbolische
Wissenschaft einnahmen. Jemand sagt, diese Arbeit sei eine
philosophische Arbeit, ja, aber sie hat
Gleichungen, so
dass sie entstehen werden  etwas
anderes
ähm und dann
dachtest du, eine Zeitung zu lesen würde
das Spiel verändern,
aber das Lesen mehrerer Zeitungen ändert das
Spiel und es ist in gewisser Weise wahr, dass es
mehr
Rottöne zu beachten gibt,
denn
zumindest unter einigen
Normen und Vorlieben für Diskussionen auf Papier
wie persönlich  Ich bevorzuge
und fühle mich zu Hause, wenn Menschen
nicht ausführlich
von dem sprechen, was eine Person dachte, und die
endosomische Perspektive von ihnen einnehmen
oder von einer ganzen Kultur, die mir unglaubwürdig erscheint
,
aber
den Exosus ihrer selbst
in Beziehung zu einem Nicht-Trivialen setzt
Endosymbiose
und wo treffen sich diese beiden
Fäden in der Decke,
die
in ihrer möglicherweise elegantesten groben
Körnung
dargestellt wird  durch das graue Kästchen hier
und warum sollten wir abgrenzen
oder gar greifen wollen,
vielleicht sind die Greifer, die wir an dieser
Stelle
haben, wie
Autozangen
und das ist etwas ganz anderes
und oder etwas Aktives,
also
scheint es zu diesem oder jedem Zeitpunkt
absolut gültig zu sein
sich die Struktur von Abbildung zwei
und drei anzusehen
und so viele Positionen
auf einmal zu halten oder in schneller
Navigation, also
wow, was für eine lustige Diskussion,
danke Steven für die Teilnahme an Blue und
Dean,
und wir werden uns auf einige
interessante Zeiten in
Punkt 2 und darüber hinaus freuen  also
friede mit
dir